hello hello this is lucello your
friendly neighborhood poly fellow
whether you're an advanced learner
intermediate or complete beginner I have
a very special offer for you to consider
over Thanksgiving dinner it's the
biggest and baddest offer with ever give
it and if you do not partake you may
never be forgiven I'm just joking about
the forgiven part but the offer is
serious and it's only available for a
limited period 50% off my ebook and both
of my courses which you can enjoy from
the Comforts of your
home the courses are available in
English and in Spanish act now because
by midnight on Monday the 27th of
November this offer will
vanish happy language Journey